now i know that you're going to say he's
got to step down
first of all though can i ask you what
you would be doing to try to protect his
reputation if you were representing him
today
well i think he's trashed his own
reputation over many many years and
i think what we're seeing today is the
inevitable consequence of having elected
somebody like boris johnson as prime
minister in the first place
uh it's not as if the country didn't
have lots of warnings about the sort of
person he was the sort of person he is
and the way that he conducts himself in
public and private life and
i don't know what i would say to him to
be absolutely frank because i
well one i wouldn't be there
but secondly
i think that i have the sense that
there's now a culture in there that
basically says johnson can thinks he can
do what the hell he wants and that has
now spread to other people as well so i
honestly don't know okay you're asking i
know you've got to you've got to fill
the tower because you've got no tory
ministers on uh and i can't pretend i'm
going to stand in for them uh but i
honestly don't know what i would say to
him other than as you said earlier
it is better to stand there at the
dispatch box and tell the truth but the
problem if he stands up and tells the
truth
is that uh which would be you know
pretty rare thing of itself but the
problem with that
is that then he's probably and almost
certainly going to have to admit that he
broke the laws that he brought in and
that he told the entire country we had
to live by and the vast majority of
people did
enormous in so many cases enormous
sacrifice and that is why this has
become such a
toxic sulfurous issue for him
yeah i'm trying to be even-handed though
uh aleister and i know and my viewers
know that you are very good at advice
you um did it incredibly well for a long
time while you were at number 10. give
it a go what would you say to him to try
to get him off the hook
you know as you you said it fess up be
honest
um
and if it come now that is that is
difficult because the truth is as i say
they we're talking now about breaches of
the law
just talk about
messing about and some of the stuff that
politicians sometimes get up to we're
talking about a breach of the law at an
incredibly difficult point
um but i think that it's always best in
these circumstances because the but the
other thing that's happening now
is because within the so i still know a
lot of people inside the civil service i
know people are leaving at the moment
because they can't stand what's going on
but what happens when you have somebody
at the top who is basically saying i can
do what i want i will blame other people
i will throw other people under the bus
that's when people in your profession
then get all the calls and the leaks and
all the rest of it that is going to
continue and continue and continue
until this guy actually stands up and
starts operating by basic public
standards that most of the public expect
him to one of which is you level with
people
so stop lying stop blustering stop
pretending that you haven't done
anything wrong and instead admit it
accept anything that comes your way with
that apologize to the country and then
try to operate in a different way but i
don't think he's capable of doing it i
really don't
we did a yougov poll um on sky yesterday
a snap poll to find out what people um
thought and this is uh what it looks
like um 27
of people so almost a quarter of more
than a quarter of those that we asked
still felt that he should remain as
prime minister even if he did break the
rules
well it doesn't actually say that he
just says do you think bryce johnson
should resign from his role as prime
minister whether that number would
change if you actually if it was proven
that he had broken lockdown rules i
don't know but listen that is not a good
position to be in you're talking about
you're so good at what you do alistair
because you immediately extrapolated
something different from that from what
i was just illustrating
no but i actually i think for any prime
minister to have a situation where fewer
than a third of people
uh think you should still be doing the
job you've got to remember kate most of
the time most people just kind of get on
with their lives and politics is
something happening over there
and you give them a poll i'm not a great
fan of instant polls i'll be absolutely
honest about that because they just tend
to reflect a passing mood but the fact
is you know as a country
we've just got to decide whether we
think that the situation that we've had
over the last couple of years is
tolerable and tenable and the other
thing i think that's really important to
draw out of this this isn't just about
boris johnson these conservatives have
now been in power for over a decade and
if it's true by the way and it's
interesting you can't get a minister to
come on this morning but if it's true
that yesterday at the cabinet meeting
this is something your colleagues have
been saying
that this wasn't even raised by a single
member of the cabinet then they really
are an utterly spineless craven bunch
this is something that is affecting the
good governance of the country and that
is something for the entire cabinet to
address
what do you think about um
what's been happening as far as the met
is concerned we know of course
that um while uh tony blair was prime
minister he was questioned under caution
about something different but
nevertheless they came forward and
wanted to talk to the then prime
minister um should they be talking to
this one
well it's a very interesting comparison
and i do think whether it's the way that
the media have covered this whether it's
the way the political system and
parliament have covered this if you go
back to that case that you mentioned
relating to tony blair that was an
investigation mounted on the basis of a
single claim by a single snp mp and on
that basis the police got involved and
as you say they got sending yates of the
year trampling all over downey street
and all the rest of it we have a
situation in relation to the breaches of
lockdown
regulations or laws where there is
plenty plenty of evidence that you'd
have thought was worth investigating and
at every step of this way
the line has been we don't have evidence
we don't have evidence to investigate
well your job is meant to be to find
evidence when you think that there may
be um there may be have been breaches of
the law now
we heard yesterday the metropolitan
police are in contact with the cabin
office
i don't know what that means but at the
time
let me tell you there were two things
going on at the time
this party was was happening one is
the police were arresting and cautioning
people
who were gathering in groups of more
than two outside in you know several
hundred i think it was at the time
and the second thing to say is that the
day after this party boris johnson was
out clapping on the steps of number 10.
i mean the hypocrisy is what gets me in
this as well and yes i do think the
police have got to you cannot have a
situation where people think that the
police is just an arm of government
and you've had the sense with the met
that they've been bending over backwards
to try not to get involved in this if a
crime has been committed in the garden
of downing street or anywhere else in
downey street and bear in mind this is a
place where it's probably got more cctv
over it than any other building in the
country so don't tell me the police
don't know what's been going on
okay it's good to talk to you thanks i'm
trying not to take it personally every
time you have a pop-up at the media on
twitter by the way it's good to talk to
you thank you very much thank you
bye-bye